[Music]
welcome to
session 45 of the world of speculative
fiction series this time we're going to
be looking
at two novels which are
connected but quite different by the
same author
a canticle for leibowitz which many of
you have probably read by walter
m miller jr if you haven't read it
already you're definitely going to want
to get it
and then the follow-up to it which came
many decades later st leibowitz and the
wild horse woman
which actually was not completely
written and finished by walter miller
we'll talk about that in a moment he did
in fact have
a ghost writer who who helped him
out with the process and finished it up
after walter miller's death so it is a
certain respect a posthumous
novel rather than one written in his own
lifetime or rather
one published in his lifetime it was all
pretty much written within his lifetime
and the world that's being depicted by
these
is is quite a rich one as we're going to
discuss
so worlds of speculative fiction is a
series that i started
five years ago partnering with the
brookfield public library
here in the greater milwaukee area it
was originally
a face-to-face session we've recorded
all of the sessions and you can watch
previous ones
and in each of them what i would do is
come in
and give a bit of a talk and we'd do a
lot of you know
discussion and back and forth and i
focused in
on worlds we looked at
books and series that had a coherent
narrative world
by speculative fiction authors so
speculative fiction everything from
fantasy and sci-fi
all the way over to alternative history
utopian novels
horror weird tales and everything in
between
and we would look at the the narrative
world that was created
which involved some discussion of course
of plot and character as well
but really looking at the world building
if there is some
in in those novels or short stories or
whatever we were looking at
and then we would talk about the
biography
and importance of the author but we'd
also get deep
into philosophical themes that were
being
raised by the stories that we were
looking at and we would sometimes use
philosophy to try to illuminate that
so in this one we're going to be talking
as i said about these
two particular novels and the world
involved in it we're also going to talk
a bit about
walter miller's own story i think
understanding that can help you
grasp better what is going on
in these stories it adds a richer
texture
and experience so we'll talk first
about walter miller's own life
walter miller's biography i think is
quite helpful for understanding
what originated these two novels
and why they're such a massive gap in
between them
both in terms of years and perhaps also
you might say in terms of structure if
not
setting and theme and content so
walter miller is born in 1923
in new smyrna beach florida and we don't
actually know
that much about his early years his
biography in part because
he doesn't tell us that much and there
aren't a lot of records that biographers
have have come across
we do know that he went to the
university of texas
and studied engineering there that's
going to turn up
to some degree in some of the
discussions in canticle for
leibowitz he didn't get a degree instead
when world war ii is going on he
he enlists in the army air corps
and at first he's involved in in radio
makes sense engineering right what we
would normally nowadays call the signal
core
and then something really fateful
happened he was assigned to become
a tail gunner and in the bomber that
that he was in and bomber crews are very
tight and close-knit
um they flew over italy
uh and sometimes it says 53 sometimes
they say 55
somewhere in the middle 50 missions
and one of the missions was particularly
fateful
it was the bombing of monte casino which
if you you know don't know much about um
the benedictine order or
religious history probably won't strike
you as being
that important but
it was a monastery that had been
established a very very long time ago
by by saint benedict who is the
you know founder of the benedictine
order one of the most
important orders in western monasticism
which
incorporated things coming from the east
there's a whole story that could be told
there long story
short uh germans
because we were you know fighting the
the germans in italy at that time had
taken up positions we're using it
as a a place for
their own soldiers if i remember the
story right it was either for
anti-aircraft or
artillery like a spotting station
and so it was targeted for bombardment
now this
was a great loss of course because
bombing a monastery is reducing it to
rubble
and as it turned out by the time that
the bombing raid took place which miller
was in on
the germans had left there were just uh
some monks there
and then about a hundred or so civilians
who had taken refuge there
and it was you know in many respects a
catastrophe
valuable uh artifacts were destroyed but
the loss of human life
and in particular you could say uh
non-combatant or even innocent human
life
that was that was a real blow and that
weighed on on miller as we're going to
talk about
later on uh he comes out of the
the army and he gets married to anna
louise becker in 1945 his wife who he
would be with
except for a brief separation for
the remainder of his life they actually
have four
children together and you know
we don't again we don't know really that
much about
his biography other than things that
people have said his children
are fairly reticent about talking about
him
he became kind of a recluse later in his
life
his agent actually didn't meet with him
face to face for years and years and
years
and so you know this is kind of a
tough one to to say an awful lot about
it but what we can say is that
he in 1953 they did separate
and he lived with a sci-fi writer judith
merrill
that was in between her second and third
marriage so you know they're kind of
kind of moving around in that time
they they were you know separated
got back together and then in
[Music]
1947
miller converts to catholicism and we're
going to talk a lot about about that and
there's discussions about well how deep
was his conversion and
how lasting was it in any case he he did
um enter the the church at that time
1950 he's he's involved in an accident
and starts writing his first story that
he writes is not a science fiction story
but then from that point onward it's all
science fiction stories and he began
sending them out so from 1951 to 1957
he's he's writing several dozen short
stories which are getting published in
the pulps
and he wins a hugo award for his
um one of his short stories uh
and and he also in 1953 he gets into
kind of interesting to find this out he
gets into writing scripts
for a very very early television series
called uh captain video and the the
video rangers
and so you know there's things going on
for him at the time he's married
the the marriage goes through some some
tough periods they get back together
he does have continuous work and then
something happens that's going to be
really fateful and is going to feed into
this book he
he writes the novel that's they're
sometimes called really
novellas that would end up being the
three parts
of canticle for leibowitz and
some people have talked about canticle
for leibowitz as being a fix up story
now what is a fix up it's when you take
some
other stories that you've written and
published elsewhere in
maybe in serial form or maybe on their
own but they're all within the same
narrative universe
and you kind of patch them up together
and hey you've got it you've got a story
there so
great prime example of this would be ava
and volks
world of null a right and there's
there's lots of other ones out there
this isn't really a fix up in part
because
according to miller and according to
other people
who who've uh looked at this
there's a lot of re-crafting that goes
into it
characters are renamed uh incidents are
placed within larger context so there's
there's a lot going
on in that story and
it's eventually published canticle for
leibowitz in
um officially in 1957 it really starts
hitting the shelves in 1960.
wins a hugo award it's not actually
being marketed as
a sci-fi story although it's coming out
of sci-fi pulps
it's just marketed as a novel this
novel has never been out of print since
and so it really made his reputation
and you know you can well imagine
that after that people were
hoping to see some some new stories come
out
and here's where the story of miller
himself
takes a rather interesting turn so
he and his wife and kids moved to
daytona california
in 1960 living essentially on the beach
and miller is
offered a thousand dollar advance to
write the sequel to canticle for
leibowitz
and you know that doesn't sound like
much money at this point in time
of course um but and it was a good bit
of money back then
but it really wasn't what you would have
expected for
something that would have won the hugo
award and was you know going along like
gangbusters
he only writes about 50 pages at that
time and then he goes
into a a slump
and there's a lot of discussion about
what what went on there
he becomes kind of a recluse he doesn't
go to the sci-fi
conventions he doesn't like doing that
sort of stuff he really withdraws a lot
from
everybody as a matter of fact there's a
very interesting piece out there on the
web
about somebody who is teaching science
fiction
in a local community college i believe
it was or a four-year college
in the area who contacted walter miller
and said hey could you know i don't want
you to like you know have to be put on
the spot but could you
could you come into my class and just
let my students ask you a few questions
you don't have to give a lecture or
anything and miller said
i'm having writer's block i i just can't
do it
and his agent um you know
said that there were really two things
that were doing him in
one was depression the other was in his
agent's words
booze nowadays i think a lot of people
can recognize that miller was probably
suffering from some pretty
serious ptsd due to his wartime
experience and here's where we come back
to the monte casino
thing that stuck with him through the
rest of his
his life and it probably had some role
in why he converted to catholicism
why he wrote these things he actually
at one point in time said i was working
on the first
version of the scene where zachary the
abbot
lies half buried in the rubble then a
light bulb came over
came over my head good god is this the
abbey at mount a casino
what have i been writing and so you know
there's a lot going on there and we
don't actually have more than just
tantalizing bits of the story but
some people talk about him as carrying
out a literary
exorcism by doing that sort of like
they've analogized
it to kurt vonnegut writing
slaughterhouse five
i don't think we want to reduce it to
that there's a lot more
going on but that that certainly plays
a role in in what's happening and
um you know this book
the the follow-up the second novel
um takes a long time to produce
bantam eventually will offer him
uh an advance again and encourage him
and he manages to write 250 pages and
then he gets stuck
and these things go on and on his agent
you know is trying to get him to write
and he does manage to eventually you
know
churn stuff out and what's what we've
got here is actually
quite good i'm going to talk about the
merits of it in in just a few minutes
but there's a there's a tragic end of
the story and
it goes like this his his uh his wife
dies in 1995 and it appears that miller
has most of this written at the time
he says that writing after that became
even more difficult for him
um you know and and that it just
wouldn't work
and so his his uh um his agent
starts looking around for what we call a
ghost writer a ghost writer is somebody
who takes somebody else's writing and
adds their own you know stuff to it
sometimes finishes out things sometimes
adds some things in there and they're
trying to
as best as they can maintain the
continuity of style and plot
and thought and all these things that go
into it and so they find terry bisson
and terry bisson had worked on a lot of
other people's things before that
and terry bisson had of course read
canticle for leibowitz and so he was
actually quite thrilled he talks about
this
in an article that i'll link to
he talks about how thrilled he was to
find out that
he might be working with walter miller
and then he found out well you won't
really be working with him
the agent said i haven't even seen him
face to face you're going to work by
correspondence so he gets the
the the novel and he's like this is
actually pretty good stuff i'm not gonna
have to do that much work to
to finish this up um i'm happy to work
on it
and then walter miller kills himself
actually
the way that it it worked is in very
early 1996
he calls the police he calls 9-1-1 and
says
there's a man who's dead here you're
going to want to come and check it out
and by the time the police arrive and
it's very quick
police response time he's taken a gun
and shot himself
out on his uh his lawn the family
wanted to keep it more or less under
wraps
and they managed to do so a few
obituaries come out
of course bison finds out from the agent
that miller had killed himself
and now the question is well what are we
going to do with this work and they do
uh manage to finish it up and bring it
to press
and there it is so this
is the entirety of
the leibowitz we'll call them the
leibowitz world and leibowitz
stories and they're really quite
different from each other
i i will say a few other things before
jumping into talking about the world
so what i want to talk about are
my sort of personal connection to to the
work
and my early assessment
and how i think you know i was wrong
about that and then we'll talk about how
these works
fit in with each other but are very
different from each other so
i read canticle for leibowitz i believe
the for the very first time when i was
either in high school or
college and you know i liked it as a
story i didn't get a lot of the
you know i didn't get as much out of it
as i could have because i didn't
understand a lot of the religious stuff
and why it had to be so focused on that
but there were there were a lot of cool
aspects to it
rereading it later when i could actually
understand what was
going on in these discussions and why
the characters were acting the way that
they
they were i thought well this is a
really great book and
i first picked this up
i would say about 15 years ago and my
first
read of it i didn't actually get all the
way through it
you know i was i was so primed by how
good this
had been to read this and i i
started reading and i was like this
isn't really what i
was looking for and it seemed like
in some respects he kind of kind of
slipped you know
um but it makes sense when you when you
think about you know how many
decades had passed and how much
difference there is between a writer
who's you know actually quite young
doing this and
a writer who's much more mature writing
a
considerably larger book that has a
different structure to it
and a very different approach to let's
call it
uh religious you know comparative
religion
ecumenicity all those those sorts of
things
and rereading this for this uh this
talk here i think this is actually
you know i don't think it's as
good as this but that's sort of like
saying that
um a really you know decent wine is not
as great as
a really fine one this is this is a good
book and it's uh
it's interesting to read it's enjoyable
there's a lot going on here if you
started out with this one
i think of course it makes a lot more
sense when you're reading the second one
the other thing i'll say about this so
so structure right
this this book is divided into three
you know navalettes fiat homo
fiat looks and fiat voluntas tua those
are latin
for you know let there be a human being
let there be light and let there be
let your will be done or let there be
your will right um
and this is only 300 pages long
311 i think to be exact
now 300 313 this
is one continuous narrative
and it is uh
a good bit longer it's 434 pages
long and it's centered
well there are other characters who are
pretty central in it
but it's really centered around one
monk from saint leibowitz abby
blacktooth goes by other names as well
nimmy
and and brother saint george and things
like that
whereas in each of the three novelettes
in this one
it's uh different characters there's
different things going on
it's in in a way this is a little bit
more like
isaac asimov's foundation where a big
story is being told
from different points of the development
of something
something that transcends human beings
in that case it's the foundation out in
space in this case
it's essentially the uh the church
and um the leibowitz in order
and and what's going on with that so
they're very different in structure um
they're not fundamentally different
in style except that you can say that
there's a lot of things discussed in
this work
that wouldn't have been discussed in
this work for example
sexuality uh of all sorts of uh
you know different kinds of acts and i
mean it doesn't he's not going into
lurid detail about it
but it does play a role in it and
there's a lot of
uh there's a lot more space for thinking
about
different religious perspectives than
there is perhaps
in in this one where it's more about
what's going on within monasticism
the larger church um
[Music]
and in relation to say unbelief or or
you know sort of a secular world or
something like that
so these are these are quite different
books um but they are
occupying the same narrative universe
so both of these novels fit solidly into
the
genre speculative fiction that we call
post-apocalyptic
and i mean you could say that there
that's that's a variety
of sci-fi as opposed to like say fantasy
or horror but it's actually been
recognized as its own sort of
thing there's a lot of overlap between
these these different
genres and i mean you could also think
of it as sort of
alternate history in a certain sense as
well
not least because it's it's so
centered around religion in the catholic
church
and yet this is a story
in which vatican ii
never happened because it hadn't
happened at the time that walter miller
was writing it so it's kind of funny to
think about it it didn't start out to be
a
alternate history of the future but but
it in fact winds up
being so so the the most central
backstory stuff is that
in this world they've gone through what
they call the flame deluge
and you know deluge is is another
word for flood so a flood
of flames what does that mean that means
a
nuclear war and it destroyed like
large parts of the world this is
actually set in
the american southwest for the most part
although they'll talk about like you
know people up in
oregon or new york right that's how they
say new york
that many years in the future or even
places like
you know across the sea in in asia
and all that but for the most part it's
sent
it's centered in a post-apocalyptic
post-nuclear war
um area of of the
former united states and
so the the flame deluge happens
because according to you know the
records that they have
the um nations of the time
can't get along they have nuclear
weapons they get stuck
in this you know essentially
cold war first and building all these
armaments and then they start thinking
about well maybe we should strike first
and then it leads to an outright
conflagration
now a lot of human beings survive which
is
you know you know nowadays i think we
would say
if there's a nuclear war we're probably
all goners
because of the winter and fallout and
all those sorts of things plus there's
so many more
nukes now than there there there were
back then
and they're so devastating but let's
just say that
human beings do survive which is the
case in this story
they're going to be facing a lot of
challenges society
and order has broken down there's going
to be
mass casualties there will be fallout so
people are going to be dying of
radiation
sickness which is a horrible way to go
there'll be all sorts of disruptions
even in like you know the way rivers
flow
or the weather patterns and you don't
know what you can eat what you can't eat
so
we just pile up all sorts of things like
that here's where
the second important part of the story
comes along
it's called the simplification so
according to miller
the ordinary people of the time they're
like well
who is responsible for this catastrophe
that we're dealing with it's the
politicians
the scientists the engineers
all the way down to like anybody who's
literate i mean
it's sort of like what happened in pol
pots campachea when they were like you
know if you had
eyeglasses you might you might get
killed in this case it's anybody
who is viewed as being an intellectual
or a technician
they they mobs go around and kill them
and there's um you know there there's
some reaction
against this but these people call
themselves simpletons and the idea is
let's
go back to a really basic kind of
society
get rid of all these what they would
have at that time called eggheads
all these intellectuals they just
produced this horrible
uh you know destroyed world we're gonna
rebuild the world and we're going to
rebuild it without any of these jerks
so there's that going on there's also at
the same time
sort of as time goes on
a attitude towards those who
have genetic mutations uh
freaks as they're they'd be called at
that time or sports
um they try to kill them as as often as
possible they want to retain you know
sort of a pure strain of
human uh genetic material
and so you've got all that going on
meanwhile
people like leibowitz and his full name
is isaiah edward leibowitz he is himself
a technician he's somebody who works for
the government
he wants to try to find his his wife he
knows that she was in some
fallout shelter in the southwest
so he goes out to that region there's an
abbey there and he becomes a monk
basically so he can go out and look for
the fallout shelter where his his wife
is supposed to be perhaps alive and
um after a while he's like i think she's
she's probably dead and he becomes
involved with
another sort of project and that project
is to keep human knowledge alive
by doing what by finding books
and in this case at the very start
hiding them
you know burying them in in like a grave
or something like that
in barrels to keep them from being
destroyed with the idea that eventually
they'll be able to bring them out and as
it turns out
he petitions the pope to found
and order the order of saint albert
magnus
which would be bookleggers sort of like
bootleggers you know carried carried uh
liquor around these are book leggers and
they
carry books from place to place and hide
books if they get caught
the mob will kill them and that is in
fact how
isaac leibowitz who's gonna eventually
become saint leibowitz that's in fact
how he dies
and um the abbey that the the story
begins at
is saint leibowitz's abbey he is not yet
canonized as a saint and we have
you know what i should tell you about
some of the the characters and how they
they fit in here
um actually before that we should talk
about a little bit
more sort of ethnography and and the
region
so we we have these monks right the
church
the catholic church has survived it's
going to go through some some breakups
and schisms and other things like that
but it survived in part because it's a
cohesive
institution and because the simpletons
although they might go after individual
members of the church are not going
after the church on moss
and so it's able to maintain itself and
what we have is essentially something
like the dark ages when the church is
really the only
repository of culture meanwhile
in the southwest we have these
nomadic tribes and interestingly
they're obviously modeled after native
americans
but there isn't really any race of
of people at this time everything's kind
of mixed up together
and they're not really taking stock of
like say skin color or features like
that
the biggest thing that they're worried
about is are you
genetically human or do you have some
some defects that have been caused by
radiation
if that's the case then you're what they
if it's really noticeable you're what
they call a gleb
and you're outside of society these were
often
early on called the children of the pope
uh because
you know they were supposed to be
protected they were thrown on the mercy
of the church you're not supposed to
kill them but a lot of people were
killing them
and then the ones who could pass as full
human were called spooks
and they could be any color any any sort
of you know
what we nowadays think about is race so
going back to the nomads there are these
people who shift into
a nomadic way of life out on the planes
which is is focused on uh
at least for the male part man horse
dog that trio that that work together
and they hunt uh you know animals
uh they also herd cattle and they
they live off of that you know they they
move from place to place the
way in which things are set up is
matrilineal so that
women control the breeding pits for the
ponies
and uh you know also sort of run the
show
and then the men you know go out and do
do their thing
um they develop their own religion
their own sort of ways of doing things
and it's very clear
you know what miller is doing is sort of
modeling
them off of the probably the you know
the lakota and some other
native tribes with a bit of mongol mixed
in
so that's that's part of what's going on
there's also states that are arising
in different places and one of them
texark texark
right texarkana is going to become very
important
under the hannigan's who originally were
nomads who took over that state sort of
like what happens in mesopotamia
early in human history so miller what
you see him doing is he's
bringing to bear a whole bunch of
different themes and saying that things
are going to happen
in interesting and similar ways that we
can relate to
uh in this new world as they did in the
old world
so in fiat homo
um it's it's set in
you know around st leibowitz is abby for
the most part it's before
well it's before st leigh which is saint
liebowitz right and
the the main character there is brother
francis
he is uh you know this young guy
i think he's 17 or 18 when when the
story starts
and he he wants to take his vows he
wants to become a monk of
of uh uh saint leibowitz and or of of
leibowitz abby and the abbot
arcos um actually denies him over and
over again
the capacity to take his vows because of
something that happens while he's out
there in his lenten fast
all by himself this old pilgrim or
wanderer comes by who's going to show up
in in each of these stories over and
over again
and he points out uh
something to this this guy that would be
a good stone for putting over
you know the other stones he's trying to
protect himself from the
the wolves out there actually feral dogs
and uh brother francis ends up finding a
fallout shelter
and in that fallout shelter there are
these
documents that are from
leibowitz levoit's the founder of their
their order and so this is a major find
now because leibowitz is being
and he's going through the process of
canonization the abbott doesn't want
anything to jinx that and so you know
there's somebody who comes and is the
devil's advocate you know trying to poke
holes in the story and all
all this meanwhile francis is assigned
to
the copying room and this is a very
important aspect this is
and again this goes back to medieval
europe as well
one of the reasons why we have all all
sorts of secular knowledge as opposed to
just
you know religious texts that we
otherwise probably would have lost
like for example uh seneca and cicero
is because monks copied out those books
sometimes actually adding a few things
in sometimes you know
making beautiful uh uh paintings or
you know embellishments on the side
sometimes putting crazy stuff in there
like you know trees with penises you can
find it in monastic things
they like to goof around quite a bit
jokes things like that
uh medieval manuscripts are full of
really interesting stuff
but the monks were for the most part the
people who are doing that actually
i should take that back it's not just
monks we know that there were also
nuns who were involved in this one
reason we know this bit of trivia
is blue was quite a
expensive color to use because you had
to get
lapis lazuli which came from central
asia
to to do it if you really wanted good
blue and they found this this uh
nun's skull that has lapis lazuli
in the teeth now why would that be the
case well because you licked your
your paintbrush to like get the good
fine point on it
do that enough and stuff start sticking
eventually
so we know that monks and nuns religious
orders
were involved in the copying and that is
what kept
knowledge alive
not just religious stuff not just
philosophical stuff not just literary
stuff
also technical stuff medical treatises
all these sorts of
things would be kept in monasteries as a
matter of fact what we think of as the
renaissance
was in part you know new ways of looking
at things it was
also scholars going to these monastery
libraries where they'd actually lost
track of
all the stuff that they had in their
libraries finding documents bringing
them out and then being like
look at this that was part of the
renaissance as well going back to this
that's that's part of the backstory of
what's going on
and they find things like blueprints
and brother francis copies that all
out by hand and eventually goes to new
rome
presents some stuff to the pope
unfortunately dies
in in the story then in fiat looks
uh we have another abbot abbott paulo
and he's going to be visited by a
secular scholar because now
under the hannigans in texark there is
a revival of secular learning going on a
renaissance right
and thon thadio who is the cousin
of hannigan ii comes out to the abbey he
wants to see some of the
memorabilia actually he wants to take
the memorabilia to his college
but it's not allowed meanwhile brother
corner has managed to
create a dynamo
an engine and a light bulb
and so there's you know it's really
interesting again
parallels what we know about the middle
ages
it wasn't just like secular scholars
people leaving religion behind that that
came up with all of this
science a lot of it was being done in
the monasteries the colleges the
universities
all of these sorts of religious
institutions and then they would go back
and forth with it
there's a there's a lot more of the
church state opposition thing
going on in there because hannigan is
actually
carrying out this process of
consolidation that is going to
be a you know major role in saint lewis
and the wild horse
woman which is set then about 60 years
after uh fiat looks and we're going to
come back to that one in a moment i just
want to round this out with
fiat volantis tua for anybody who's only
going to read this book
so in um fiat voluntous tua now we're
fast forwarding
many many centuries into the future
we're now in a technological age as a
matter of fact
the world has been repopulated and human
beings have even made their way
out to the stars into you know
alpha century and other places like that
they're colonizing
uh the universe but
they're also moving towards another
nuclear war
and that in fact is what ends up
happening
um and you know again saint liebowitz is
abby plays a major role we have
the abbot who now is jethros zerky who
we saw mentioned earlier when when
miller is talking about monte cassino
and he's he's writing about what happens
to zerky
getting caught in the rubble and he's
like is this what was going on am i
writing this this story there's also a
doctor who's involved who's sort of the
equivalent of
thon thaddeo you know the secular thing
and then they
argue back and forth about their
positions
there's also brother joshua who's going
to be
leading the
let's call it the the remnant
because what ends up happening is the
the vatican the new rome has planned
for not just monks
and priests but three bishops to go out
into space
so that the church can continue on
ministering to the
colonists in other worlds and
transmitting
not just the religion but also the huma
you know sort of
humane perspectives and the knowledge as
a matter of fact
you know the the the uh order of
of uh the st leibowitz is abby
and st lewis's abbey itself is is
heavily populated by
spacemen by people who have previous
experience in going out into space
so that's that's part of what's going on
with
with that story the world is being split
between an asian coalition an atlanta
confederacy
not too hard to read between the lines
and see what's going on there
now when we get to st lewis and the wild
horse woman we get a lot
more in-depth discussion about what's
going on
and it's uh you know texark is trying to
take over the entire area
as a matter of fact they're even trying
to take the papacy
so that they can control the religion
and have church and state kind of
unified in the same
and there's a lot more discussion about
the nomads
in part because we have several
characters who themselves are nomads
including the main character um
blacktooth and then uh the person who
starts out as being the the red cardinal
and eventually is going to become
pope um brown pony
and many others now there's a passage
here that i i would like to read that i
think is quite good
for talking about what was going on with
the the nomads and i'll read it here so
the future was revealed to the tribal
seers it was foreseeable that the open
plains would shrink
and the people on the and the cattle on
it would either perish or change
they had been changing continuously
through three generations since the
conquest
he goes on for whatever reason the great
planes were shrinking while their
population had been growing fast of late
was this not the chief cause
of war the tribes were restless anxious
angry they had compromised even the
wildest among them used the tools and
weapons that were manufactured
in the towns and cities to the east in
the mountains they brought their beef
hides artwork wolfskins bear grease and
surplus ponies to a trading post
then rode back to grandmother land
leading a pack mule loaded with tools
gun powder
musket balls fabric beans and enough
distilled spirits for at least the
elders to get sloshed
they sang the old songs and danced the
old rituals honored the wild people
moved their dwellings and their herds
according to the season
each horde or owned a sacred path in
sacred places along it to pitch camp for
a season they navigated the grasslands
by the doings in the night sky
as much as by landmarks the sky told
them when to move
south it was the middle of the 23rd
century
and polaris traced a larger circle in
the north sky than it did in the time of
leibowitz but the hordes called
themselves the people the pole star when
they wandered
and so this is you know part of what's
going on
they um it's an entire world
that is now being sort of revealed to us
in this and it's a world that involves
you know
machinations of church and state
and politics and you know whether the
tribes
or the hordes can be united under one
chieftain you know essentially one war
leader because
who actually holds power the
grandmothers
uh the people up in the hills and
whether the the people who
have suffered genetic defects can live a
full life
themselves or whether they're always
going to be persecuted and driven out
there's all these things
going on as a matter of fact even
connections to
lands across the sea in this book
so there's a lot more world building you
could say
going on than the brief sketches that
we're getting
in in this book and i think they do make
very nice
companion pieces to each other given
that
now we should talk about some
philosophical themes
of this work although
i don't think is really the most
interesting philosophical theme
posed by the work much of
the secondary literature and writing and
talk about this work focuses on one that
we really should
discuss and that is the notion of there
being
sort of a cyclical approach to
history and perhaps even to
time on the part of walter miller
so what do we mean by talking about
cyclical history
so the idea is that history follows a
certain pattern
and you can get to a certain point
and think that you might be changing
things but you're really caught in this
dynamic
where you're going to wind up at the
same place as the
last cycle and this is quite a popular
view of history
you know those who like to you know
talk about america as the new rome
and how you know the roman empire fell
to these things and it all depends on
whose
uh version of roman history you're gonna
you're gonna look at
right uh you know so if you're a walter
if you're if you're a gibbon person
then you know you stress these things if
you uh
look at other things you stress other
factors the idea is that you can have
the same
basic dynamic happening over and over
again
and it doesn't really work that way
every time that you look closely at
these you see that at best what we have
are circles that overlap to some degree
but aren't exactly the same cycle if you
want to simplify
so that you actually get away from
history and you're dealing with
something more like
mythology or ideology well then you can
have as
you know easier circle as you want
now what would be the cycle
for miller's story so if you use
canticle for leibowitz
it's pretty straightforward you've got a
big
cataclysm something destroys society
including the you know the actions of
human beings both those who like
unleash terrible weapons and it doesn't
necessarily have to be weapons it could
be environmental disaster it could be
whatever
and then you have the other humans
responding to it in ways that are not
particularly helpful and actually make
things worse the simpletons
and then you rise out of that
by means of having some sort of cohesive
community that has greater values than
just eat and drink and and you know
copulate
and reproduce something else that
they're devoted to
that produces knowledge as kind of a
side effect
and the knowledge begins to spread and
and you know you you essentially come to
the point where you leave the dark ages
and get in you get through the high
middle ages and the renaissance and this
you know great flowering
of things then you move into another
modern period
and then you get to a late modern period
where everybody's you know got it you
know fairly
easy but we create new weapons
and we don't control them and we we
haven't really learned the lessons of
history
and then we blow it all up again right
except that
in this case um
they did learn the lesson the church
and and the people who have colonized
elsewhere
they get the hell out of town they're
like we know where this goes
you know uh it really was a bad thing to
blow up the world last time
this time maybe nothing's going to
survive and actually by the end of the
story
i'll just read this to you so here's the
two
vignettes that end it they sang as they
lifted the children
into the ship they sang old space
chanties and helped the children up the
ladder one at a time and into the hands
of the sisters
they sang heartily to dispel the fright
of the little ones when the horizon
erupted the singing stop they passed the
last child into the ship
the horizon came alive with flashes as
the monks mounted the ladder the
horizons became a red glow
a distant cloud bank was born where no
cloud had been
the monks on the ladder looked away from
the flashes when the flashes were gone
they looked back
the visage of lucifer mushroomed into
hideousness
above the cloud bank rising slowly like
some titan climbing to its feet after
ages of imprisonment in the earth
someone barked an order the monks began
climbing again
soon they were all inside the ship the
last monk upon entering
paused in the lock he stood in the open
hatchway and took off his sandals
sick transut mundus he murmured
looking back at the glow thus goes the
world
right he slapped the soles of his
sandals together beating the dirt out of
them the glow was engulfing a third of
the heavens
he scratched his beard took one look at
the ocean and stepped back and closed
the hatch
there came a blur a glare of light a
high thin whining
sound and the starship thrust itself
heavenward so
you know he there is a cyclical element
to that we've learned our lesson
but the other part is let's get the hell
out of here you know and let's let's
move on with hope for humanity
remaining humanity i mean remember the
first one
the first story is called fiat homo
let there be human i mean let there be
man is how a lot of people translate it
let there be humanity right
the second part is this the breakers
beat
monotonously at the shores casting up
driftwood
an abandoned seaplane floated beneath
beyond the breakers
after a while the breakers caught the
seaplane and threw it on the shore with
the driftwood
it tilted and fractured a wing there
were shrimp carousing and the breakers
and the whiting that fed on the shrimp
and the shark that munched the whiting
and found them admirable in the sport of
brutality of the sea
a wind came across the ocean sweeping
within a pall of fine white ash
the ash fell into the sea and into the
breakers the breakers washed dead shrimp
ashore with the driftwood
then they washed up the whiting the
shark swam out to his deepest waters and
brooded in the old clean currents
he was very hungry that season we don't
know whether life is
completely ended on earth but much of it
has
and so the cycle i mean if it is a
cyclical history it's like
wow you know last time you really
screwed it up
this time it's done so
you know we could talk about cyclical
history and we could also talk about
you know repetition of historical motifs
in saint leibowitz and the wild horse
woman
what we have here is a discussion about
you know
uh church politics and the ra the
relation between church and state
and how those things seem to repeat
themselves you know there's there's
schisms
there's uh you know attempts by the
the secular world to to take the church
and turn it to its own ends by
controlling
who is elected as pope who gets to be a
cardinal
all of those sorts of things and
religious people
being confronted with you know all sorts
of possibilities should i
should i sell out to the state should i
try to help these people
over here what's the right path for the
church to go
all of those sorts of things so people
want to
read those those matters into it i would
say we're dealing
less with a completely
cyclical motif of history
and more with miller trying to tell us
this is how we could screw things up
some people have pointed out that
there's nothing inherent about the
technology itself
for miller that brings us to
the these issues whether of domination
by some
some tyrant or
of uh destruction of the the world that
we all have to live in
through the use of of uh weapons and he
doesn't just talk about
um nuclear weapons there's also the use
of biological weapons
in st leibowitz and the wild horse woman
as a matter of fact
even in this in the uh fiat
uh looks the hannigan uses biological
warfare
against the nomads to break them to kill
their
their cattle
and st lewis and the wild horse woman
it's used
biological weapons are used against
people by by
the uh texark forces so i think that
that um again it's it's better to talk
less of
directly cyclical history where we don't
have any choices
and it's more thinking about cautionary
history right um the technology by
itself
isn't necessarily good or bad as a
matter of fact some people call
miller a technophile saying that
technology
is actually a good thing but we have to
be very careful about thinking that
technology by itself without changing
the human condition
changing the human heart changing the
way our societies work
is automatically going to make things
better and not simply
say replicate power structures or
domination or exploitation
or conflicts that are going to take
place
for us a second philosophical theme that
i would say
is absolutely central and inescapable in
these these two novels
is the meaning and role
of religion i mean this is all
happening at a monastery and
at least you know a third of the
important characters
in this story including the two most
important characters
uh blacktooth and brown pony are
religious so you know what is
miller doing by by thematizing
religion part of what's going on i think
is and you can see this with the the
vast array of characters you know when
we
when we generalize about religion and
particularly when we generalize about
the church meaning the catholic church
and about
monks we're actually engaging in
something that's that's kind of
sloppy thinking a lot of the time and we
have to be
careful that we're not painting as we
say with too broad a brush
every monster if you ever read monastic
literature you you
very quickly come to realize that people
become monks or nuns for
very different reasons and have very
different experiences and
one monastery is not even though they're
under the same rule
say benedict's rule they interpret it
differently and apply it differently
and there's different things going on so
you know you
you don't go to a monastery to escape
the human condition
you wind up entrapped in it even more
and and you know sort of trying to
understand it all the more in
in a monastery even if you go out to the
desert by yourself as a hermit you can't
escape
the human condition so figuring out the
meaning
and the the value and the demands of
religion
is in fact a major part of this and and
you have characters
this is part of what i really like about
the work in some respects he reminds me
of other
authors like iris murdoch or evelyn
waugh
or graham greene where
becoming religious or being religious
does not solve your problems for you it
actually complicates your
your existence and you have all sorts of
things where
you know what you know the teaching is
but then how
how to apply it what's the right thing
to do um
and and there are people who are in it
as examples you know blacktooth is a
prime example
who are religious and they do
follow as best as they can what's being
taught or what they've internalized as
their religion but they're doing it
poorly and they know it to be the case
you know for poor blacktooth over and
over again has so many
so many hard uh uh situations he does in
fact find a teacher
in uh almond speckle bird who becomes
pope
and who's almost very much i think is
really modeled after like a zen
abbot because uh miller got into eastern
religions quite a bit
so let's talk about what religions
are mentioned or or play a role in this
obviously you know there's a lot of
discussion
about how one lives out monastic
life and the importance of vows
there's there's really i think there's
some really great sort of
representations
of some of the sacraments in in this you
know what's going
on when somebody confesses
and you know what counts is a good one
there's baptism being discussed as a
matter of fact
the uh final story the
fiat voluntas tua ends
with an attempt by the abbot to baptize
what what's essentially like a child
who's grown out of this this woman
and the child doesn't doesn't allow it
but does
take the eucharist the you know the
bread
um so there's a lot of of that sort of
stuff and there's also sacramentality i
would say
of of other sorts you know there's some
some sacramental engagements
with the um nomads
religion which seems to be modeled again
off of
some native american things with with
again
some some eastern things mixed in there
as well and then there's discussions of
others so we we actually should talk
about
not just um you know the the church in
relation to the nomads but we should
talk about the the whole
range of religion that that's being
presented and explored in this so we we
do have
lots and lots of discussion about
catholicism
and we do have quite a bit of discussion
about what's going on
within different things in the the nomad
religion including belief systems
where there's for example a
three-fold aspect to
one of the divine beings who's present
as
the night hag uh the the maiden
and also as the vulture of of war
right so there's there's all of these
things
figured into it but there's also
interestingly
that's not in the first novel but in the
second novel there's a lot of stuff that
if you've been reading
you know if you've been reading buddhist
in in particular
zen literature you'll come to recognize
in
some of the discussions that people are
having particularly the pope
almond speckle bird who is a mystic
right you'll also
recognize if you've ever read meister
eckhart some discussions
uh coming up in there and then there's
there's
also eastern religions brought in in a
kind of vague way
you know there are these um
[Music]
warriors who are
asian and origin came from a church over
there
wind up being part of a cardinals
um retinue or you know bodyguards
and they are
essentially warrior monks they they
teach other
monks how to fight too as well it's
never quite
clear what their status actually is
and where they came from that's that's
not really narrated and then there's
also another character
wushin who plays an important role
in it as well who used to be the
executioner for the hannigan the the
texark
authority guy and who
then um you know leaves
he's sort of under disgrace and he's
sort of a weapon master
and he gets a lot of lines in there
where he talks about you know
sword taking life but also giving life
and
and there's a you know as both brown
pony
and as a black tooth can can can
easily realize and identify and tell us
in the story
there is a spirituality involved there
so what's what's really interesting
is that miller doesn't dogmatize
what miller does in his stories and he
doesn't didacticize either he doesn't
tell you a story about
the good monk and the bad monk and you
know who the good monk is and who the
bad monk is and
you know very clear by the end of the
story what you're supposed to do and
what you're not supposed to do he
doesn't do that sort of thing
in many respects he's like philip k dick
or or like iris murdoch
and or graham green
putting these characters out there
another person he's like in this this
respect theodore dostoevsky
characters are there they're trying to
figure out their own
salvation or duties or relationships
and they've got religious guidance which
is sometimes helpful
sometimes not they know that they have
to
to act and make choices this is another
issue that we're going to come to in a
bit
and they wind up you know sort of
communicating a perspective that i think
walter miller himself
has now interestingly
we mentioned that you know miller had
converted to catholicism and i said
nobody's really quite sure how
stable how deep a conversion this
this actually was or would turn out to
be
he writes a letter to the editor of a
local paper
shortly after his wife's death where he
says that eastern religions
make it clear that personhood is an
illusion
and he talks about his wife as you know
if she exists at all it's within you
know me
and you know um she had a she you know
is a great person but also had a mean
streak and then he says but i've i've
also got enough a mean streak and i've
got enough room for both of our mean
streaks
and the idea that he that he seems to be
conveying there is
there's twofold right there's the sort
of
endorsement i think on his part of a
less personal centered more you know
traditional buddhist
uh conception of of human beings and
then there's also this while we carry
the people around with us
in our hearts in in you know how we we
care about them or
something something along those lines
you could say
and um you know i think that's that's
that's quite meaningful so
religion is going to play a really
central role
in this but it's not as if there's
something that you can point at and
simply say
aha there's the essence of religion
rather religion is being
explored in it not in every single
possible aspect of it
but in many many central aspects of it
and in several different
representative faiths in walter miller's
works i think that a
third important theme of these two
novels by walter miller
jr is the let's call it the distinction
but also overlapping and intersection
of of three important areas
of human existence part part of what
makes us
human and one of these is
the political sphere and that's where a
lot of different things are going on
that we'll talk about in just a moment
another is the sphere of religion
including religious institutions so not
just people having beliefs
but actually having some sort of
organization to it whether it be the the
nomads out on the plains
or the actual church itself
you know having survived the flame
deluge and
having you know ecclesial structures but
also monastic structures
and then the third thing we could we
could call
the realm of technology and
science and and maybe we actually should
distinguish
those two apart from each other because
there's an there's a tendency to blur
them
together and all three of them appeal to
really basic fundamental human
needs desires experiences
so you know let's come back to the the
political
right we we have to live together in
community as
aristotle says we are a political or
social animal
meaning that we we have relations not
just with our immediate families
but with neighbors with people who we
live with and with
larger people inhabiting larger spheres
in which we have some things in common
and in which we also disagree
about certain moral values and and you
see that you know really
especially in in this you know follow-up
novel but it's also there in canticle
for
leibowitz ins as well and
when things can't be done properly
when things go off the rails in the
political sphere
that's when everybody else suffers
particularly
when those making the decisions have
uh been armed by you know the scientists
or the technologists
and so that's that's a really you know
key idea
there are people who are you could say
political creatures so
for example in saint leibowitz and the
wild horse woman
um nimmy or or blacktooth
he's not really a political person he's
he's a
religious person who also feels some
you know some allegiances to the nomads
where he came from and he falls in love
with
somebody else we'll talk about that in
just a bit in another theme
with eldra but brown pony is
totally a political animal he just
happens to also be a cardinal
and to be within the ecclesia ecclesial
structure then he ends up being pope
for a while although not acknowledged by
the the hannigans and the texark
forces and the the person who has
elected pope prior to him
uh amon specklebird he
is he's a mystic right so he's he's a
religious person he's not
actually a political person but it gets
steered in in political ways and
so there's all these things going on and
what is politics
fundamentally about you could say that
part of it is about
human competition with each other who's
going to run things who's going to
to rule who's going to call the shots
and when things degenerate into just
rival factions then we've got some
serious problems
but the political is also about how do
we live together
as human beings how do we orient
ourselves towards
securing certain basic goods that we
need how do we handle
conflicts within the community and
conflicts of the community with
larger forces other communities in many
cases
how do we deal with that and then you
know as aristotle pointed out as well
the the political sphere is is partly
where we decide what things are going to
be studied so it impinges upon the
technological sphere it impinges
upon the scientific sphere and we can
say that the religious
sphere does that as well so
let's also talk about the the religious
fear obviously
we're looking at um religious
institutions
in canticle for leibowitz it's uh monks
and abbots who
are the main characters in each of the
three stories and of course they play a
major role in this but we do also have
some people who
are not religious or don't start out as
religious
as important characters in st leibowitz
and
the wild horse woman and we have other
religious structures and organizations
being brought in as well
those in particular of the
nomads out on the plains where it's
connected together with their politics
in
in different ways than it is with the um
you know the city-states and the texark
empire and
and the church the other thing that we
haven't talked about so far other than
to say well maybe we need to make a
distinction here
is the scientific and technological
sphere you know as human beings we
are technological creatures you could
look at language itself
as being technology and we've been
supplementing
the what our bodies are for you know
for centuries and centuries using a
crutch is is a form of technology
so we are creatures who do don't exist
without some sort of connection with
technology but you can use
technology without actually
understanding it or understanding the
effects that it's going to have
or how to fix it and part of what's
going on
in these these stories is a
history of technological recovery
and misunderstanding and then you know
recuperation
and inventing new things and it's
interesting in the second story in in
fiat looks
that there are some things that are
being recovered from before the flame
deluge right
but for example the circuit that brother
francis
you know traces out and illuminates
but there's other things that are being
invented
grasped that weren't coming from the
flame delusion they might be repetitions
of things that were lost from the
previous civilization right but
they they're also the product of human
ingenuity
and you can say well why do people
create technology
and there's actually a couple different
answers to that that i think are quite
relevant here
one is people see a need and they're
like man i wish i had something that
could do this
right and so you know if you think about
in in
fiat looks the uh light
you know filaments the the essentially
light bulb
and the generator that's being produced
it is um
it's it's being done in order to
illuminate
the manuscript room so it's got a very
practical utilitarian purpose
yet at the same time um
brother what was his name uh
kern um there we go
yeah brother uh kerner
he invents the dynamo not because
it's to satisfy some need but there's an
intellectual curiosity there
also a use of intuition as the the
scientist recognizes that allows him to
explore and this is part of what makes
us human
we we have a desire to understand to
experiment
and to to know to have knowledge and
science is really in in part not just
about
finding practical applications but about
figuring stuff
out and the church could get in the way
of that or the church
could promote that and it can be you
know not just the church
as a whole but individual monasteries or
abbots or you know other things within
it
can promote or stand in the way of
of that the the narrative historically
of um religion and science has never
been so simple as
religion is simply holding science back
that was
you know nonsense that was created
during the enlightenment to try
to sort of justify throwing away the
past
and miller is really playing with us
likewise there's an interpenetration of
the religious
and the political sphere we see that
very very clearly
in all the machinations going on in st
lewis and the wild horse woman
where they're they're you know
essentially uh competing
about who's going to rule the church
so i think that's another really key
aspect
of this this narrative a fourth
theme that we could call an ethical
theme
is something that the characters
themselves
are undergoing and taking part in in
these stories
and that's that they have to make
choices
and usually they're trying to make you
know good choices
at least the characters who are being
narrated and who are telling us about
their
motivations and things like that and
these these choices have to do
with values and they also have to deal
with what we can call loyalty to
something
something transcendent something greater
than them and so this ties in very
closely with this
the third theme that we just talked
about you know the intersection of the
political sphere
the religious fear and then the
scientific and technological sphere
which might actually be
two different spheres in each of these
cases
there's there's something that is not
just pure self-interest in the sense of
like
survival or getting rich
or having power over people the
political and the religious
could be about that so could the
technological but the people who are
being driven
by these and and who have genuine you
know dilemmas to deal with
it's not just about those and it's not
just about vanity either
these things that are that are really
self-centered it's not totally removed
from it
either and actually in this this one
blacktooth
you know is really going through a lot
trying to
fathom you know whether his his motives
are good motives or not and i think you
can say
something similar is happening with the
characters in canticle for leibowitz as
well
so over and over again people
have to to make decisions and take
stands that can
often get them put in danger or even
killed
coming into conflict over things that
they think to be bigger than them
and to make demands upon them so each of
the abbots for example
in canticle for leibowitz and in saint
libous and the wild horse woman
they have a number of different
imperatives in mind an abbott is
somebody who
rules the monastery in fact in the
catholic church they have the same power
within the monastery as a bishop has
over their diocese
and so you know they have to make a lot
of difficult decisions and that's
why they're elected to become abbot
every monastery is a microcosm of human
beings with all sorts of problems
arising
conflicts between the monks and what
they think ought to be done
and the abbots have to to figure out how
to how to deal with that
as a matter of fact the one abbot
actually has like a
essentially like a stomach ulcer because
of
all of these responsibilities on him
that he has to to deal with
and you can say similar things about the
popes
you know in in uh wild you know st
lewis and the wild horse woman also the
the
um the pope who made the decision to
send off the
clergy and children and the
um the bishops into space
you know they're having to plan
providentially and they're having to
take difficult stands
which may in fact and in the case of
some of these characters do
get them killed or result
in them maybe feeling like they're
wasting their
their life i think you know what's
really interesting
is in the case of canticle for leibowitz
everybody's basically making the right
decisions
they're not viewed as right necessarily
by everybody around them
you know great example of this is
brother francis engaging in this
illuminated manuscript and the robber
who takes it away from him says you
wasted
all those years of your life on this and
brother francis kind of
there's a moment where he's like maybe
it was a waste of my
my time i mean what makes it a waste is
that this stupid robber took it away
from me
and then you know he goes and and sees
the the pope and the pope gives him some
money to buy it back and of course
brother francis isn't able to because a
spoiler alert he gets killed
and he gets killed basically so so
somebody else can eat him
but does that mean that the sacrifice
is simply in vain i think the message
that walter miller is giving us
in what each of these characters is
doing is you know you can't guarantee
that what you do is actually going to
turn out
to to have you know the effects that you
want but it can
all be done if not you know for the
greater glory of god for the
greater glory of something at least some
something that has
a transcendent value it could be god it
could be
comradeship it could be the community it
could be truth
it could be progress there's all sorts
of
possibilities but we see characters who
are in fact devoted to it
and we see characters you know doing
similar things in st leibowitz and the
wild horse woman the
different nomads who you know some of
them
are trying to unite their peoples um the
the
the genetically affected people
living up in the hills who are trying to
produce their own community
where their kind can live even the the
the hannigan is you know who runs the
ostensibly evil empire of texarkana who
does do some pretty underhanded stuff
like biological weaponry and all that
he's he's not a
totally bad person in this
he's trying to produce a you know a
greater
civilization and so you've got all these
people who are making these important
decisions and then we have
blacktooth nimmy brother saint george
all these are names for the same guy
and he has to make similar decisions
over and over and over again where his
loyalties
truly lie and he makes a lot of
good decisions and he also makes in in
his own you know view
in retrospect some bad decisions and
sometimes he'll like go to confession
and talk about that
sometimes he's absolved sometimes he
isn't
um but i think that that's that's a
really cool thread you could call it an
ethical motif running throughout this
this work
and of course this work as well so the
last big theme that i want to talk about
really
doesn't run through canticle for
leibowitz
at all but it does figure heavily in st
leibowitz and the wild horse woman and
it's it's something that i i might be
wrong about this but i think that miller
is weaving in
a tale of lovers who can't
truly be together in part because
although they do love each other and
they do in fact
have a kid together and all these these
things you know
are are going on and they're able to be
together for a while
the the situation it it just doesn't
work out and
the the requirements after you know
because
uh one of them is a monk and then the
other one becomes a nun
those are going to keep them apart as
well and now if you know the story
of eloise argentale and abellard
i think you can recognize some common
elements
in the connection between black tooth or
nimi
and aedra who is a spook she's a
genetically
modified person who can pass
as as fully human and um
she's not supposed to reproduce as a
matter of fact she has her genitalia
sewn up
so that uh you know she's not going to
be able to do that and her father's
the one who who commissions that because
they're not supposed to do that
and um she and and blacktooth end up
meeting very early on in the thing and
she steals his rosaries she steals his
guitar she kind of taunts him and
they both desire each other and they
wind up together
and they they do some other things you
know because they can't have
what we might call normal procreative
conjugal love kind of sex
that that you know is uh normative in
this case
and um she does manage actually
later on to get herself pregnant uh
through you know some interesting means
that you can read about in there
but what what's really i think
interesting about this
is that she is actually an agent
for her people working with the the
vatican
and against the um the empire the texar
tex you know so
she's really you know she's smart she's
beautiful
she's uh attractive to blacktooth she
has attracted to black tooth
they want they have a destiny together
in a way and yet they can't be together
over and over again the cardinal and
then the pope
brown pony says you stay away from her
don't don't get involved
with this this woman and over and over
again
uh they they do wind up being together
and she
has a child sort of like you know eloise
and abelard had a child who heloise
named
uh astrolabe she was so into the science
of the time they were both brilliant
scholars by the way
and the the child is is given up um
and and likewise the same thing happens
to blacktooth
and eldre's child and he tries to track
it down is he's unsuccessful
in that and you know i think this is a
good
fitting place to end the very end of
this
is um after everything has collapsed and
all the plans have broken down
blacktooth survives and
here we go
he rode unchallenged past the first log
outpost of the glep
he hoped the valley of the mistborn
would take him in and it did the valley
or the watchaton nation as it was now
called
had grown to be a network of valleys up
and down the low mountains called the
olds arcs
blacktooth wandered until he found a
little community of book leggers and
memorizers called post cedar
he traded his mule for guitar much like
his father had given him
and lived on the mountain side above the
abbey swapping his services as a scribe
and a tutor for food
he found shelter in a rock house cave
very much like the cave where ammon had
lived
except that these eastern caves were
broad and open like a mouth
they protect they provide protection
against the rain in some against the
cold but none against the years
and so blacktooth saint george grew old
reciting the divine office and
meditating upon the rule of saint
leibowitz
which enjoined him to the humility he
was surprised to discover had been
waiting for him all along it was a
sister to the deep loneliness he
treasured
a loneliness he no longer wished filled
it was an emptiness as tangible as love
some nights though he found himself
praying to whatever might answer such a
prayer
that aedra would come to him he had
heard that a blonde spook who wore a
nun's robe practiced medicine in the
next valley
the local priest called her a witch
sometimes
she healed minds the priesthood cursed
and because this the priest
feared her and you know it goes down a
little bit
[Applause]
here we go and um
blacktooth you know eventually dies and
then
the last chapter just over the mountain
from post-cedar was a convent where
there lived a nun known as sister claire
she awakened one morning with one of her
feelings and knew that the hermit who
lived
in the next valley was dead she'd known
of him for years but had elected to
leave him in peace knowing the
difficulty of the journey he was on
no one told her he was dead no one
besides herself knew it yet and she only
knew because of the feeling
not unlike joy and not unlike sorrow
either that wouldn't leave her she
welcomed the feeling
the hermit had few enough left in this
world to miss him
with the abbess's permission sister
claire packed a loaf of bread a little
cheese and then as an afterthought
a freshly dead mouse from the trap in
the kitchen she walked over the steep
and little used trail to post cedar
on the far side of the valley across
from the monastery
she found the narrow path to the dry
cave just where she knew it would be
the old man hadn't been dead long it was
not his death but his age that filled
sister claire's eyes with tears
she had expected somehow to find a
handsome young man even though she was
herself an old woman bent and spotted
with years
blacktooth was sitting against a stone
with a head of a small cougar in his lap
the animal lifted its blue head when she
approached it was librata
aedra waited but the cougar wouldn't
leave and finally had to be coaxed away
with the mouse so that she could
bury blacktooth and place at the head of
his grave the little cross
she carried with her all these years the
rosary that was clutched in his hand and
the crude guitar he had left leaning
against the back wall of the cave she
took with her
and that's that's where it ends sad
um hard to you know
bring everything to a close that way but
that's that's the that's the story and
what we have here is a in addition to
all the other themes that are going on
a kind of eloise and ambellard tragic
lover story as well coming from the
middle ages
so that's uh what we have to say
about these two excellent novels i hope
you
read them and get as much out of them
as i have on the rereading
you